♪ ♪
>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
GEORGIA PUSHING DEMOCRATS TO
BLOW UP LONG-STANDING FILIBUSTER
RULES OF HIS PARTY CAN FLOW
THROUGH VOTING RIGHTS.
REPUBLICANS ARE BLASTING IT IN
THE DEMOCRATS WITH THE MIDTERMS.
>> President Biden: JIM CROW
2.0 IS ABOUT TWO INSIDIOUS
THINGS.
VOTER SUPPRESSION AND ELECTION
SUBVERSION.
I'VE BEEN HAVING THESE QUIET
CONVERSATIONS AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS FOR THE LAST TWO MONTHS
AND I'M TIRED OF BEING QUIET.
TODAY, MAKING IT CLEAR.
TO PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY, I
SUPPORT CHANGING THE SENATE
RULES, WHICHEVER WAY THEY NEED
TO BE CHANGED TO PREVENT A
MINORITY OF CENTERS FROM
BLOCKING ACTIONS ON VOTING
RIGHTS.
THE CONSEQUENTIAL MOMENTS IN
HISTORY, THEY PRESENT THE CHOICE
DO YOU WANT TO BE ON THE SIDE OF
DR. KING OR GEORGE WALLACE?
>> Jesse: WHAT A PUPPET.
BUT GUESS WHO COULDN'T BE
BOTHERED TO SHOW UP?
STACEY ABRAMS, ANOTHER ACTIVIST
WHO DECIDED TO SNUB THE EVENT.
THE ACTIVIST SAID THEY'D HAD
ENOUGH OF SPEECHES AND PHOTO OPS
BUT BIDEN DOESN'T SEEM TO THINK
THERE IS ANY BAD BLOOD BETWEEN
HIM AND ABRAMS.
>> ARE YOU INSULTED HE'S GIVING
THE SPEECH?
>> President Biden: I'M
INSULTED HE ASKED THE QUESTION.
WE HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP, WE
HAVE GOTTEN OUR SCHEDULING MIXED
UP, WE ARE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
AND EVERYTHING IS FINE.
>> Jesse: DANA, DO YOU GET
YOUR SCHEDULING MIXED UP WITH
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
>> Dana: WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYS I'LL BE
THERE TOMORROW AT AT TEN, YOU
DROP EVERYTHING SO YOU COULD BE
THERE ESPECIALLY IF IT'S YOUR
SIGNATURE ISSUE.
REMEMBER, SHE NEVER CONCEDED SHE
HAD LOST ON THE GEORGIA ELECTION
AND SHE'S BEEN TRAVELING THE
COUNTRY ON A SPEAKING TOUR TO
TRY TO DRIVE THIS MESSAGE HOME.
IN FACT, ARGUABLY SHE HAS DONE A
LOT MORE TO TRY TO ADVANCE THIS
ISSUE THAN BIDEN AND HARRIS HAVE
DONE.
NOW AT THE LAST MINUTE BECAUSE
BUILD BACK BETTER DIDN'T WORK
OUT, YOU HAVE THE ADMINISTRATION
WITHOUT EVER HAVING GIVEN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE A SPEECH ABOUT
WHY THIS NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
TODAY WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS
I'M TIRED OF BEING QUIET, HE
YELLED THE ENTIRE TIME.
WHILE HE IS DOING THAT, THE
NAACP PUTS OUT A STATEMENT
SAYING, YOU HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH.
THEY ARE GOING TO UNDER DELIVER
AND MAKE YOUR ELECTIONS ARE
ABOUT TURNING OUT THE BASE.
THE FACT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
CAN'T EVEN WORK TOGETHER ON THIS
AND A STACEY ABRAMS IN GEORGIA
HAD A SCHEDULING CONFLICT, I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE WHAT THAT
PHONE CALL WAS LIKE.
I'M SURE THAT BIDEN AND STACEY
ABRAMS HAD A CHAT TODAY BUT SHE
DIDN'T CHANGE HER SCHEDULE.
WHAT WAS SO PRESSING THAT SHE
COULDN'T BE THERE WITH THE
PRESIDENT TODAY?
THERE ARE SOME STUDENTS IN
ARIZONA AND SOME OF THE COLLEGES
SAYING THEY ARE GOING TO GO ON
HUNGER STRIKE UNTIL THIS LAW IS
PASSED AND OF THE CHANGED.
SO KEEP HER EYE ON THAT.
>> Jesse: I HOPE THEY HAD A
BIG DINNER BEFORE THEY ANNOUNCED
THAT.
MAYBE STACEY ABRAMS WAS WRITING
ANOTHER ONE OF HER EROTIC
NOVELS.
>> Greg: I HAVE ALL OF THEM AT
HOME.
ORIGINAL COPIES I MIGHT ADD.
>> Jesse: YOU MENTION AT THE
TOP OF THE SHOW HOW THIS SEEMS
RIDICULOUS IN LIGHT OF
EVERYTHING GOING ON IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Greg: IT'S GREAT WHEN HE
MENTIONS GEORGE WALLACE BECAUSE,
WHOSE SIDE WAS JOE GEORGE
WALLACE ON?
HE BRAGGED ABOUT THE FACT HE
LIKED JOE BIDEN.
MODERATE JOE IS DEAD.
HE'S BURIED.
WHAT YOU THOUGHT THERE WAS, HE
SPLITTING THE COUNTRY IN HALF
WITH DIVISIVE EARSPLITTING
RHETORIC LIKE IT DEMENTIA A
RIDDLED TRANSIENT SHOUTING AT
CLOUDS.
I MEAN, IT'S ALL FOR SOMETHING
THAT, I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING
TO BE ABLE TO PASS WITH 48
VOTES.
SPEAKING OF WHICH, HOW CAN HE
KEEP REDEFINING MAJORITY AS
MINORITY?
WHICH SIDE HAS MORE VOTES THAN
YOU BECOME A MINORITY, I DON'T
GET THAT.
AND WHAT VOTING RIGHTS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT DENYING?
AS FAR AS I KNOW IT YOU'RE AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN YOU ARE A
CERTAIN AGE, YOU CAN VOTE.
IS HE TALKING ABOUT A MURDERER
WHO DOESN'T HAVE AN I.D.?
BECAUSE I WANT TO KNOW WHO WE
ARE DENYING.
TO ME IT SOUNDS ALL ABOUT IT AND
PEOPLE TO VOTE AND GETTING IT
AND MAKING IT EASIER.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OUR
REPUBLICAN PATSIES.
YOU GOT PLAYED BY THE DEMS WITH
A JANUARY 6TH ANNIVERSARY.
I'M WONDERING NEXT YEAR HOW THEY
ARE GOING TO USE JANUARY 6TH
AGAIN, WHAT CATASTROPHE WILL THE
NEXT ANNIVERSARY FEET INTO?
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO FORCE MORE
CRT IN THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE
OF JANUARY 6TH?
EVERY YEAR WE GET TO LOOK
FORWARD TO THE USE
OF JANUARY 6TH AS A PLOY TO
CREATE A SCARED POPULATION, TO
SCARE THEM STUPID SO THEY ARE
ACTUALLY ON THE SAME WAVELENGTH
AS JOE BIDEN.
>> Dagen: I LIKE GREG'S POINT.
THIS IS LIKE, JOE BIDEN AND
COMPANY ARE NOT READING WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
THIS IS WHEN YOU INVITE A LOT OF
FOLKS TO A PARTY ENDED SCHEDULED
AT A VERY CONVENIENT TIME, IT'S
RIGHT AFTER WORK.
YOU JUST HAVE TO COME BY RIGHT
ON YOUR WAY HOME.
IT'S ON THE BYPASS, YOU KNOW, I
LIVE IN AN APARTMENT.
IT'S NEXT DOOR TO HER OFFICE
BUILDING.
YOU CAN COME IN, I GOT PUNCHED,
I GOT WHITE CLOTH, WHATEVER YOU
NEED TO.
NOBODY SHOWED UP TO BIDEN'S
PARTY AND I'M SURE THAT THEY
ANTICIPATED WHAT HE WAS GOING TO
SAY.
BRINGING UP GEORGE WALLACE?
THEY WOULD BE STANDING ON STAGE
WITH A STEAMING, FLAMING SACK OF
JOE.
IN TALKING ABOUT GEORGE WALLACE?
AND AS GREG POINTED OUT, HE WAS
A DEMOCRAT BUT BIDEN ONCE
BRAGGED ABOUT WALLACE PAYING HIM
A COMPLIMENT.
AND HE ALWAYS BRING THIS UP THE
EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE NAMED AFTER
GRAND DRAGON AND THE CLAN.
JOE BIDEN GAVE A EULOGY A LITTLE
MORE THAN A DECADE AGO FOR A
FORMER EXALTED CYCLOPS OF THE
CLAN, ROBERT BURDA.
SO HE CONSTANTLY REINFORCES THE
FACT THAT HE IS OLD AND USED TO
BE FRIENDS WITH RACIST AND
SEGREGATIONIST.
>> Jesse: IN THE LIAR ROLE
FROM BIDEN, THE STATE'S CRACKED
DOWN ON BIDEN.
BUT THEY JUST MADE IT EASIER TO
CHEAT.
>> Geraldo: I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY WAS A PRETTY GOOD
SPEECH THAT GOT WASTED.
THE VOLUME WAS NAILED
UNFORTUNATELY BUT THE LANGUAGE,
A DAGGER AT THE THROAT OF
DEMOCRACY AND A TURNING POINT IN
THE COURSE OF THE NATION, YOU
WOULD THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
THING.
BUT WHAT IS VOTING RIGHTS REALLY
ABOUT?
I BET MOST OF US HAVE MOST OF
THE PETER MIKE PEOPLE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S THE LEGISLATION.
>> Jesse: I DO.
LET ME READ IT TO YOU.
HERE I GO, AND ELIMINATES VOTER
I.D., ELECTION DAY STARTS TO
WEEK BEFORE THE ELECTION AND
THEN YOU GET AN EXTRA WEEK TO
COUNT THE VOTES.
SO ELECTION DAY IS ACTUALLY
THREE WEEKS.
A MASS MAIL OUT ABSENTEE BALLOT
APPLICATION MAKES IT HARDER TO
CLEAN UP THE VOTER ROLLS AND YOU
DON'T EVEN NEED A SIGNATURE ON
YOUR ABSENTEE BALLOT.
AND GERALDO, IT IS MY FAVORITE.
THIS IS MY PERSONAL FAVORITE.
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO SERVE FOOD AT
A POLLING STATION.
CAN YOU SMELL THE BARBECUE?
I WOULD VOTE DEMOCRAT IF I WAS
HUNGRY.
BUT I WILL VOTE FOR WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO.
>> Geraldo: JUST BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A PRIME TIME SHOW DOESN'T
MEAN YOU GET TO GLOM MY TIME.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, WHAT
IS THIS ABOUT?
THIS IS ABOUT MAIL IN BALLOTS,
THE REGULATIONS WERE LOOSE
BECAUSE OF COVID.
SO YOU HAD A HUGE FLOW OF
MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
I ASSUME THEY WERE LEGITIMATE
MOST OF THEM, BECAUSE OF THE
VARIOUS REVIEWS THAT TOOK PLACE.
SO IT'S ABOUT THAT AND IT'S
ABOUT VOTER I.D.
AS A MEMBER OF A RACIAL MINORITY
AND ALSO 10% NATIVE AMERICAN, I
RESENT THE NOTION THAT PEOPLE
LIKE ME ARE TWO INCAPABLE OF
GETTING A VOTER IDENTIFICATION.
GETTING AN I.D. CARD.
WHY DOESN'T EVERYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY, IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
NATIONALIZING ELECTION, IF
NATIONALIZING ELECTIONS MEAN
THAT EVERYBODY GETS A VOTER
I.D., MAYBE WITH THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER WRITTEN
ON IT, EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE AN
I.D.
EVERYBODY IN THIS COUNTRY SHOULD
HAVE AN I.D.
AND IF YOU HAVE AN I.D., YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE, AND IF YOU'RE A
CITIZEN OF THE COUNTRY AND YOU
HAVE THE RESIDENCY REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHED, YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO VOTE.
NOW, MAIL-IN BALLOTS, THE
PROBLEM IS HARVESTING BALLOTS.
THEY SENT THEM EVERYBODY AND YOU
HAVE SOME SLICK START GOING DOOR
TO DOOR, I WILL HELP YOU THROW
FILL IT IN,